howie would you
here's what's amazing about you
among multiple things is that you have
been famous for
40 years
at least yes 45 years infamous and
i think we can all agree that is a hard
thing to do right to stay
to i mean this is america it's an ultra
marathon to keep working you're still on
incredibly popular shows your daughter
actually likes you you weren't for a
chunk i wasn't right before deal or no
deal i was quitting the business
what what do you mean quitting like he
was done i was done i wasn't doing
anything and what do you mean not you
were just like moping around the house
are you doing your podcast or mine
you want me to tell you i'm gonna ken
pen's showing up pretty soon
i i feel like it's okay for me to be
fascinated by like you're a very famous
person i'll tell you the truth the truth
is that right before this 2005 i had
done i have more failed pilots not even
they didn't even get to air than you can
even imagine i had everything i've seen
all the memorabilia yeah it's
memorability of my failures i have
behind i have the same thing in my house
i got a warehouse i didn't want them
where i live yeah and that's a that's
the deer that you hit uh with your car
right no that's a talking deer
yeah what's he saying
what's he saying
what do you say what did he say
is it that's amazing
can derail a conversation like that yeah
what an amazing not saying anything
i thought he could talk so you would you
were out of the business and then nbc
you know like in the end silverman was
like please do dealership in the 80s i
was i blew up in the early 80s and then
by 2005 i was uh going from comedy club
to comedy club empty comedy club to
empty comedy club
at that point no i just had i like
wandering and they and they and i had um
i was sitting in folding chairs and
casting offices reading for five lines
and under and then i got a call uh from
i'll tell this really quickly i got a
call i i am fascinated by this and
please
take your time telling it i am not
kidding i know you see me
i know you're not kidding i know you're
not kidding me i love this [ __ ] i would
love to to go on somebody else's podcast
and i don't have to say anything and let
them tell two-hour stories
[Laughter]
all right so you're reading under five
lines you're like i was the star of
saying elsewhere i you had a huge
stand-up career and it's all going away
come sit here all right
wait can i touch your headphones yeah
aren't they all don't have to be
he's medicated a guest on my own show
joel mchale howie mandel guests on joel
wow
i wish i had some uh what's it like
working with my daughter
she's delightful except for all the
systemic racism she spews out all the
time
no i'm cancelled
no no i'm not going to say it i'm just
you know saying that maybe read a couple
books
all right thank you so howie wow the the
headphones are way better
my voice is popping in this it's great
not popping in the uh sound booth bad
way but in a good way so howie yeah
you're reading you're like i'm out
because i'm i'm not getting any roles
well you know i had done i as you know i
invest in other things because i didn't
trust uh you invested in your family
that's right you raised sensible
children you raised a co-host i raised
the cost
again so you could keep working and i
don't and i only have to do half the
work for one thing right yeah i mean now
i'm not even co-hosting no you i can't
this is going to be great so
it's 2005. yeah
and i get a call i had i said this is so
[ __ ] horrible it really is it's a
horrible business it's a hard business
and it's like no joke no and it's
humiliating and it's it's tough and it
keeps getting tougher
and and i go i don't need this at this
point in my life so i was in my mid 40s
and i get a call from my manager and
goes uh nbc would love you to be the
host of a game show before i even got
game show out i hung up the phone right
and then you sanitized it
it's always sanitized before i pick it
up oh well done in 2005 they said would
you like to do a game show i hung up the
phone because at that time right no
comedian had done a game show the game
show us who whose currency is uh irony
the game show uh host was the
yeah they punchline for whatever reason
it didn't make any sense because so many
game show hosts throughout history have
been marvelously talented and for
whatever reason they were
the bottom of the barrel and it's like
if you did that you can't do anything
well the only one the last one who did
it before that was groucho marx who did
it brilliantly on you bet your life
which i think jay is doing though
well no there's there was multiple when
hosts i mean i'm comedians uh no i'm not
saying comedian i'm just saying a game
show host a person that was put into
that category uh were always like very i
always thought they were like very funny
and very good but for whatever reason in
our silly business it was like the same
thing we're like oh you do tv you can't
ever do movies right and then unless you
get rea unless you become michael j from
this but that only happens in once in a
while but i felt like i was being
humiliated and then i didn't want this
kick in the in in the ego anymore and i
wanted to get out and to get this call
saying you want to be a game show was
going to be the nail in the coffin of my
career so i said no and i hung up the
phone and then they called back a minute
later and they said no this is not like
you think this is bigger than anything
this is going to be and they've never
done this before nbc is going to give
five
uh nights to prime time hours and
they're going to launch it and it's a
huge game all over the world and i went
are you [ __ ] kidding me no that's
even more of a reason i can be
humiliated like 10 times more than
organic scale at four o'clock in the
afternoon maybe nobody's going to see it
but on a gigantic scale but it was in
prime time he calls me back the last
time they go they can't do it without
you can he just show you the
uh can he just show you the game
and he is who it turned out to be uh rob
smith who was at a company called
endemol
and i was at jerry's deli in the valley
and i said i'm not going anywhere but if
he wants to show up i'll sit here i'm
having like i'm having enough corned
beef to soup that's it you're having
that weird that's all he ever said isn't
that weird that you're here today and
i'm telling the soup story amazing camel
toe yeah tattoo okay
so he shows up
and i thought i was being punked because
he shows up with this board it looked
like uh like a seven-year-old had done
an after-school project he made 26
squares you have the board here i'll
show you the board after yeah you took
the board home he takes everything home
do you see this warehouse i'm a hoarder
yeah with some real estate well the good
thing about your hoarding is that it's
all very clean most of it is there's the
dealer no the old card
you took it off the wall
this shitty little card which was in
jerry's i thought i was being punked he
brought this little card in
wow and and these things and he goes
okay pick one of the squares and he goes
the game but but there is no [ __ ]
game you know there's no game there's no
i know there's no game it's opening as
we said on the suit which is like
opening containers with howie mandel
right uh
you were right it wasn't even a joke
right but it still is gambling uh but
that said
this does not communicate the scale of
the show
well the point is whenever if you're
looking at the picture i say look at
this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ] little thing
and then two weeks well let me tell you
the story and then and then
because i'm going to ruin the the end so
you're not there you don't there's
nothing to ruin you're doing
great it's just it's not about it
but like i'm gonna nail this like it's
not a talk show a good story it's a
great story i just want you to be you
on my podcast yes
you're great
people care
so issa that's cleaning
i know it's very exciting okay so wait
but this does not show that okay go go
ahead so well it doesn't end so the guy
says to me uh we need you to do this
show i don't know he goes we can't do it
without you and this is such a big
commitment and worldwide success it
already has that america is the last
country to get on board
and i go home and i
say to my she goes are going to do it
and i go i don't think so she goes you
know what howie take the deal just do it
just to do it because you're miserable
you're at home you're miserable and
i go this is going to be so embarrassing
i phoned back to nbc and i said i'll do
it when do you shoot and this is a
friday they said
monday and i well wait don't you have to
build a set and they go we got it built
i go well don't you have to hire 26
models they're there
so however just for the amount of down
the list was i
why they needed you said no to this job
here's the revelation the soup had just
started and they asked me to do that
is that real
no no oh
so many lies
but for a moment
she believed it and then how he's like
wait a minute i'm gullible oh he wasn't
the first host
anyway the thing is that uh um you
didn't take the show because this stood
out to you took the show because mom
wanted you out of the house right
so but i questioned for you also because
so you hadn't been working in years a
long time nothing successfully what
about money were you like no i did well
it would be nice to have a big check but
you know i'm not one of those people
because i am desperate i think every job
i take is the last one so so do i from
the first job i had and that's why i
have always invested and i've always
been involved in other businesses my
i tell this to people right but still
but in the back of your mind but you
were able to take years off yeah you're
saying and the investment's just paid
well i'm in business i do business well
i do business too
what business are you in hold on before
we get to that why won't you answer a
question why do i have to answer
questions on my own podcast i know i
will talk about investments and stuff
like that it's not answering questions i
am saying what this is like an actor or
a comedian do you
ha because this is what i have this
desperate feeling i'm like well this is
this is my last one yeah this is the
last finally i leaned into that right
and i said i don't want that yeah just
like get out of the house it wasn't just
that it was like they're going to write
a pretty huge check right out of the
gate for doing this no they weren't even
offering me a lot of money no
they absolutely did no well not not
enough to say i'm going to like but you
taped how many episodes in what period
of time six episodes six episodes in
three or four days uh
they did what was it one episode uh two
episodes a day somebody here that was
with me right so three or four days all
those people are so old they've passed
away but uh you're right that's why
they're tattoos
these are their these are their
grandchildren who
are so great that they're here they can
talk about the old days but
uh because i because when i think that's
the secret about game shows is that
you can tape them so quickly right and
you get paid well right
but it wasn't about the pay and they
weren't paying me phenomenally wasn't
your wife just a little bit like hey and
it's a pretty damn good check so no not
the money it was more about getting me
out of the house i'm really annoying
can you tell at no point it was anybody
arguing the opposite
[Music]
you